[Música]
rusia putin en moscú no hay duda uno de
los elementos más polémicos de donald
trump está siendo su aparente
fascinación por rusia y su carismático
líder vladímir putin e insinuaciones
mensajes de apoyo y la elección de altos
cargos muy cercanos al kremlin el
presidente electo donald trump y nominó
como secretario de estado agrega
steelers en presidente de la exxon mobil
la mayor petrolera del mundo el tejano
de 56 años recibió una condecoración
rusa por su amistad con esa nación la
pregunta es esta trump intentando
seducir al oso ruso o como dicen algunos
hay algo sospechoso en esta relación lo
cierto es que la apuesta de tram por
rusia podría tener una explicación según
cada vez más analistas los asesores del
nuevo inquilino del despacho oval
quieren dejar su huella emulando el gran
éxito político que richard nixon y henry
kissinger tuvieron con chinas
nixon seduce a la china de mao el 21 de
febrero de 1972 se produjo uno de los
acontecimientos más importantes de las
últimas décadas ese día richard nixon
llegó a pekín fue la primera visita de
un presidente de eeuu a la china
comunista
un gran paso para nixon un desconocido
paso para la humanidad como si de unos
juegos olímpicos o un gran espectáculo
se tratara todo el viaje fue ampliamente
retransmitido por televisión
por este motivo millones de personas con
tuvieron el aliento mientras
presenciaban a través de sus pantallas
como richard nixon bajaba las escaleras
del air force one y ponía su primer pie
en la capital
comer
pero antes de nada retrocedamos un
poquito más para ver qué implicaciones
tuvo esta visita cuáles eran sus
objetivos cómo fue posible vayamos hasta
el 1 de octubre de 1949 ese día se
proclamó la república popular china
los comunistas liderados por mago habían
ganado la guerra por el poder de china
la animadversión del nuevo régimen chino
hacia washington era total de hecho tan
sólo un año después las tropas del
ejército chino intervinieron en la
guerra de korea para apoyar al régimen
de pyongyang enfrentándose así cara a
cara con el ejército de eeuu
[Música]
por supuesto tras esta lucha a cara de
perro que supuso la muerte de miles de
soldados en ambos bandos desapareció
cualquier intención de establecer
relaciones diplomáticas casi podemos
decir que desde ese momento chinos y
estadounidenses se habían declarado odio
eterno para qué [ __ ] tienen que
mudarse los amarillos a este barrio
mientras tanto las relaciones de pekín
con moscú ya os podéis imaginar eran muy
diferentes es verdad que mago nunca se
había llevado bien con los líderes
soviéticos que de hecho habían apoyado a
otras personas para liderar el partido
comunista chino sin embargo a pesar de
tener muchas diferencias tras la
proclamación de la república popular
china la alianza era casi inhabitable
por un lado la unión soviética tenían la
imperiosa necesidad de controlar o al
menos tratar de influenciar a la otra
gran potencia comunista por el otro la
china de mao necesitaba desesperadamente
la ayuda de la urss la unión soviética
ayuda económica tecnológica y militar
y es que atención porque la ayuda fue de
tal magnitud que entre 1954 y 1959 la
unión soviética se gastó en china más
del 7 por ciento de todos los recursos
del gobierno en esos años
hay quienes dicen que fue la mayor
transferencia de tecnología de la
historia del mundo a pesar de todo ello
poco a poco las diferencias políticas
sobre prácticamente todos los grandes
temas fueron apareciendo y erosionando
así esa alianza hasta llegar a la
ruptura total la tensión crecía y crecía
y si en 1967 la embajada de la unión
soviética en pekín fue asaltada en 1939
se produjo el primer gran choque armado
el conflicto no fue más allá pero
durante unos días se temió incluso que
éste diese lugar a una guerra abierta a
gran escala bueno es que moscú hasta
llegó a plantear el envío de tropas del
pacto de varsovia a lo que se opuso
rumanía e incluso fijaros se dice que
ante el rumor de un ataque nuclear
disuasorio nixon se comunicó con moscú
para dejarles claro que eeuu no
aceptaría bajo ningún concepto esa
posibilidad
[Música]
como fuese el caso es que las relaciones
entre las dos potencias comunistas se
rompieron por completo en ese momento
tanto nixon como su célebre asesor de
seguridad nacional henry kissinger
decidieron hacer suyo ese conocido
proverbio popular de el enemigo de mi
enemigo es mi amigo así que dicho y
hecho se pusieron manos a la obra y en
tan sólo dos años nixon ya estaba en
pekín las relaciones entre estados
unidos de china avanzaron lentamente de
hecho no fue hasta el 79 con jimmy
carter- en la casa blanca cuando se
establecieron relaciones plenas pero lo
cierto es que el viaje de nixon dio paso
a una época de entendimiento cuyos
resultados son incuestionables si en
1972 el comercio bilateral no llegaba ni
con mucho a los mil millones de dólares
hoy se aproxima a los seiscientos mil
millones
hasta ahora las relaciones han sido
relativamente cordiales y eeuu se
aseguró un aliado contra la unión
soviética en plena guerra fría
[Música]
pues bien según muchos analistas eso es
precisamente lo que persigue hoy trump
reeditar la estrategia de nixon y
kissinger sólo que cambiando a pekín por
moscú eso explicaría la inclinación
obscenamente prorrusa de donald sin
embargo hoy las cosas son muy diferentes
a 1969
[Música]
el vídeo entre china y rúsia desde
finales de la década de los 80 las
relaciones entre china y rúsia fueron
mejorando poco a poco un tratado por
aquí un acuerdo por allá pero la llegada
al poder de xi jinping en 2012 lo cambió
todo desde entonces la relación entre
ambas potencias ha avanzado a toda
velocidad fijaros que decía en 2016 uno
de los pesos pesados del gobierno chino
la profundidad y el alcance de
coordinación entre ambos países no tiene
precedentes y es que al parecer xi
jinping y vladimir putin han cuajado
buenas relaciones personales pero sobre
todo pequeña ha visto la posibilidad de
ganar muchos puntos en su carrera por
conseguir una influencia internacional
acorde a su posición económica
una alianza entre china y rúsia sería
muy poderosa desde cualquier punto de
vista de momento hoy los dos países
cooperan como nunca antes en 2016 rusia
se convirtió en el primer suministrador
de petróleo de china un petróleo que
además amigos de visual político llega
por tierra lo que es muy importante para
china porque en caso de conflicto
eeuu no podría bloquearlo algo que sí
podría hacer a día de hoy con los
suministros por vía marítima
[Música]
además sobre los dos países han
comenzado a realizar asiduamente
ejercicios militares conjuntos han
impulsado también los vínculos
económicos y tecnológicos y se han
puesto de acuerdo para sacar adelante
infraestructuras que conecten sus dos
países
queréis tres ejemplos de todo ello pues
atentos a estos ejemplos y son solo tres
primero los ejercicios militares
sin rusia a corazón su alianza con
maniobras en el mar de china meridional
segundo los vínculos económicos china y
rúsia salían para destrozar el duopolio
aeronáutico de boeing airbus y tercero
las infraestructuras a este respecto que
mejor muestra que está cuando esté
finalizado el punto y sobre rio
gerencian será el primero de su tipo con
una longitud de mil 283 metros y la la
ciudad china de geijo con la rusa tvsz
en esquel y ayudará a impulsar el
comercio entre las dos naciones tras 28
años eso es una prueba de amor no os
parece pero aquí no acaba todo por si
fuese poco ambos países han firmado
importantes acuerdos militares por los
que china se va a gastar miles de
millones en adquirir algunos de los
equipos más modernos del ejército ruso
como por ejemplo los sistemas de misiles
tierra aire s 400 o la joya del ejército
popular el schüco y 35 aquí podéis ver a
esta preciosidad
y junto a todo ello muchos acuerdos
económicos monetarios políticos vamos
que eeuu tiene motivos para estar
verdaderamente preocupados sobre todo si
tenemos en cuenta que los intereses de
ambos países parecen estar bien
alineados contra un enemigo en común
washington
amenazas al amor chino ruiz
pero un momento antes de echarnos a
temblar ante el tándem chino ruso no
todo es de color de rosas puede que
ambas potencias se hayan acercado
posturas pero aún son muchos los
elementos que les separan o al menos los
que pueden debilitar esta unidad china
quiere por encima de todo hacer valer su
relevancia económica en términos
políticos y eso implica por ejemplo
convertirse en el líder de esa central
su plan sobre la ruta de la seta que
vimos en este pasado vídeo sigue esa
línea por supuesto de esto moscú no
quiero oír ni hablar en su opinión los
espacios soviéticos tienen que quedar
bajo la influencia exclusiva de moscú
por otro lado las relaciones económicas
también plantean divisiones para rusia
existe un claro desequilibrio en los
últimos años se han convertido en un
suministrador de recursos naturales para
china mientras que este país inunda el
mercado ruso de bienes manufacturados y
de mayor valor por el lado chino su
posición respecto al comercio
internacional y el modelo económico es
mucho más pragmática los chinos quieren
ganar dinero saben que para ellos
abrirse al mundo es bueno una visión que
moscú no
parte precisamente y luego está también
el problema con algunos socios rusos
como la india de la cual es el mayor
proveedor de armas algo que no hace
especial gracia a pekín
en fin y aunque ambos países acerquen
posturas y se apoyen mutuamente contra
eeuu no esperemos de ellos una relación
excesivamente sólida y amistosa al fin y
al cabo
tarde o temprano china querrá ser el
líder en la relación y eso difícilmente
lo aceptará moscú
[Música]
es factible el plan de trump la verdad a
día de hoy el plan de trump de reeditar
la estrategia a nixon no parece muy
factible es cierto que trump en china a
su principal enemigo pero a pesar de
ello si quiere ganarse el apoyo de moscú
tendría que hacer concesiones que
difícilmente se aceptarían en washington
[Música]
por ejemplo la eliminación de sanciones
la cesión en ucrania y en síria el fin
del escudo anti-misiles eso entre otras
muchas
putin puede ser muy exigente y aunque lo
lograse no está claro que rusia le
sirviese de mucho para la contención del
gigante asiático es por ello que obama
prefirió apostar por rodear al gigante
chino llegando a acuerdos con sus
vecinos india vietnam malasia y en esta
estrategia el pp jugaba un papel clave y
habló en pasado porque como sabrás una
de las primeras cosas que trump tumbó al
llegar a la casa blanca no suena muy
coherente verdad por cierto si quieres
saber más sobre la política exterior de
obama no os perdáis este vídeo bueno y
tú qué opinas consolidarán rusia-china
una super alianza contra eeuu logrará
trump
quitar el acuerdo de nixon pero
cambiando pekín por moscú espero
vuestras respuestas y si os ha gustado
el vídeo darle al botón de like os
esperamos también en twitter y facebook
y por supuesto no os olvidéis de nuestro
hermano pequeño visual político en
inglés un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]